bei tag und herzlich willkommen zu einem
get on video zusammen mit franz ag - tut
der auch gut und gerne auch gut in der
auch gerne gespielt und auch ganz gut
ist darin ja vorher ist voll komisch
einfach keine kriege bin ich gut
verdammt ich hab eine route die ich
immer auf diesen partys verdammt gut
routen sind voller sozial finde ich
warum also ich hab voll glück einfach
auch irgendwie keine ahnung zehn blöcke
unter der staat ebene waren einfach zwei
noch direkt nebeneinander von paar
sekunden also keine ahnung warum die
leute sich das nicht erholt haben aber
ich habe es getan so herzlich im web
atlantis ich kenne analog raten möglich
ist das weil da geht's am anfang direkt
zur drei blöcke oder vier blöcke wo man
direkt noch auf der sportgruppe aufgehen
kann hält die blöcke is born aber im
unterschiedlich
ich habe sieben und acht punkten suchte
weil ich bin da bitte ich bin halt jetzt
der zweite von und ich bin ich da ganz
oben ja ich hab gerade mal 300
schiffmann
vielleicht bin ich konzentriert gewesen
heute egal
nächste karte etwas rausholen jetzt
schon jetzt gerade nicht auch die partie
von der bank lebens findet auch nicht so
cool meine lieblings karte ist
eigentlich alles de findet lsd mario
aber das sind wahrscheinlich generell
soll die einfacheren aber irgendwie da
krieg ich immer am meisten punkten also
es gibt vielleicht ja auch klar warum
ich meine hier ist es ja so des übels
dicke abständen zwischen den platten
sind essen kommt man zu den gar nicht
gehen ich glaube hier gibt es auch ein
paar routen überlaufen könnte aber ich
finde wenn man das mit ruten spielt das
verlangen wenn ich das nicht in ordnung
ich mich schlecht
spielt er nicht ändern wurde okay okay
weil keiner hats nein runtergefallen
ok ich muss ein paar sachen auf jeden
fall sammeln so je gut
ich glaube du wirst mich aber ganz schön
fertig machen im deathmatch ja ich hoffe
ich kann echt gut entscheiden kann ich
habe letzte mal so schärfe vier
schwerter ja nett was mein video nicht
gesehen weil gefragt worum es da geht
aber da hatte ich auch gleich ein
scharfes vier feier aspect zwei schwer
gehabt dass wir gesehen ist das
heftigste equipment video jetzt freudig
falls jemand das noch schauen wollte tut
mir leid aber die meisten dürften
eigentlich schaut sie ist vor ort müssen
sogar verdammt schampus shampoos einmal
ganz shampoos kann cool sein wenn man
halt auch richtig scheiße
es gibt halt immer diese zwei hohen
blöcke wo man nicht rankommt ich hasse
foul alter junge gesagt jetzt schon die
pausen punkte was da ist geht kommt die
zweite runde
es geht aber ich meine im vergleich zu
mir besonders gut
es müssen was anderes sagen ich würde ja
gesagt hat dass man nicht ihm kanzler
ist ja anders sein team
ja man alter da würden wir kassieren
zumindest wenn ich mal gut wäre
ausnahmsweise ich hatte aber im video
hatte ich 1500 punkte seien auch schon
ganz ansehnlich aber das beste was ich
hatte waren 1900 knapp 1100 ich habe
aber war sogar mit einem in der runde
der hat 2008 das ist richtiger maschinen
2000 geht eigentlich gar nicht nadeau
des glücks maps und todes glück er wenn
du halt deine 3d film partners und
beirut oder ein verkauf
komplett ineinander oder immer 100 coins
irgendwie raus bekommen es ist ja auch
noch rennen kann man das irgendwie
schaffen aber insgesamt von tricky dick
aber mit der hand getötet darunter
geboxt einfach mit der hand getötet dich
ja bitte aber ich finde schweers das
noch einen blog und das habe ich auch
mal ein paar aus gold 685 dass nur 300
vorsprung bisschen mehr
das geht klar ich glaube ich okay ich
hab echt nicht viel gemacht im vergleich
zu larry king ist wenn wir werden wir
auf die andere runde warten wo ich euch
noch darauf hinweisen dass mein homeboy
luke young louzek young für die luca
ball cooles video hochgeladen hat der
hat nämlich ein paar unis in
ostdeutschland besucht und nicht nur er
hat das gemacht auch noch mit youtube in
tamm tamm heißt die gute die kenne ich
aber nicht als cool und ich hab schon
angeschaut das video ich finde es
eigentlich relativ stark also echt
interessant weil ihr wisst ja ich mache
auch abitur dich das und muss mich auch
noch informieren wohin ich studieren
gehen kann und so was und lukas ist echt
cool gemacht und dazu werde ich euch mal
die links zu den jeweiligen videos in
die beschreibung packen und dann könnt
ihr einfach mal vorbei checken und ja
falls ihr euch für das thema studieren
interessiert eigentlich aus jedem finden
wie ich finde interessanten bereich eine
uni besucht und sogar mein bereich war
aus deutschland ja wer stimmt gewusst
mehr berlin
ich war ja ob er auch in ich hab in
berlin waren nicht allein fahren ja ich
glaube er war super in potsdam leipzig
weimar keine ahnung
der kreis aber er war auf jeden fall
richtig coolen so viel munition aber
wurde aber schaut euch einfach an wenn
ihr wollt und das ist auf jeden fall als
starke sache weiter irgendwie in
zuge von einer kampagne das glaube ich
studieren in fernost oder so und ich
finde videos kunden jetzt und jetzt
werde ich mal sehen ob ich diese runde
auch noch irgendwas raus und kann okay
denn wenn man blind ist dann kann man
auch nicht sprinten
egal ich habe am meisten freuen
ich habe am drittmeisten ich hole mir
trotz obwohl ich viele icons soll ich
mal einfach nur einem diamond trade &
invest stellen resten level
ja ich hole mir auch ich hole mir das
meiste eigentlich immer freilich hat den
bogen vergessen ich krieg dich spiel
wieder so riskiere
ja wenn ich dir was abgeben könnt ihr
euch gerne machen freunde das ist
absolut wahnsinnig wie spieler sich so
mancher eine sackgasse entscheiden
ja ja dass das sowieso ebenfalls stadt
verzaubert immer auf level 30 ist
einfach mega geil
jetzt habe ich habe ein gutes schwert
wir kämpfen sowie so ineinander
gerichtsakten ich habe ein scharfes
versperrt da steht ja da kann ich nicht
mehr mithalten und dafür allerdings ist
nur eine 1 wobei nicht nur normale
protection verdammt wo ich muss echt
vorsichtig kämpfe jetzt am anfang und
ich bin im turm des ace director nächste
tief hoher kosten auf die runde kann das
wären max ich kann ein bisschen
unauffällig was drauf masse eines wird
er sagen ich hab drei extra hetzen alter
[ __ ] gott jetzt hat geleckt nicht
rausgeflogen frau hinter seinen mist
werden um eine mini runde dran wobei ich
glaube ich werde einfach gucken mögen
dass ich möchte viele punkte kriege
dabei nicht als ziel haben und dann
sehen wir uns im finale wieder okay
update von runde 1 512 punkte und ich
habe gewinne das thema lieblings karte
wir uns gleich ok zweite update franz
hat mich überholt
das fast 100 punkte mehr 883 punkte
jetzt kommt es darauf an letzte karte
verdammt okay wir sind fertig drei leute
die relativ viel abstand haben 1063 mit
boy ich bin dritter platz okay
los gehts einkaufen ab jetzt seid ihr
einfach wieder dabei und 22 pfeile ich
war mir noch ein bisschen rüstung ich
habe diesmal nur schlägt keine ahnung
ich kann nicht mitreden hält ist was
spaß verstehe ich nicht schön aber ich
denke mal die sachen wieder stehen ja
ich hasse dieses 17 entscheidungssystem
nachricht ja geil ist es nicht schlimm
dass es dieses rentensystem ist fand ich
damals auch nicht schlimm aber es hat
einfach schlimm dass man sich denkt du
kriegst jetzt dass unser weg richtig hat
letzten vier und habe ich dieses der
glieder vier gekriegt so auf level 30
war nicht nur neun monaten ist auch
neues oder später so ab auf die karte
sehr gut ich hab nichts sagen ich mag
die karte nicht so weil man hier sich
folglich nie so ganz neuer aspekt
geschichten werden können ja ok aber
okay die angemeldet finde ich es viel zu
viel wasser die fakten absolut und gibt
wohl gibt irgendein zwischending möglich
jetzt gibt mir die beiden glaube ich
noch folgen schade eigentlich guetta und
der spiel und so unendlich viel
potenzial für nächster macht so viel
spaß da irgendwie mal ein neues links
rein hauen würde ein neues plugin unsere
teams die vorne
das wäre nicht so knapp kommt hört mein
gold update es wollen die ich weg gerade
von dem tier angegriffen
was passiert es kommt einfach ein
dritter und greift mich von hinten an
während ich mit dem team kämpfe ich habe
in einem basta the cool ich glaube ich
bin auch gleich draußen gehen ein wasser
rein
habt ihr ein weggeholt mich natürlich
mag ich bin in der mitte ohne blätter
bist ein bisschen okay ich bin draußen
bist du bald doch das mit geklatscht
oder bist du gedacht als ob aber ich
habe mich nicht gefühlt ich habe aber
wir dürfen nicht ihm schon gesagt habe
dass man nicht hätte aber keine spieler
an sich gehen musste ich gar nicht
rechtsklick auf den spielern habe ich
gleich wieder von dem ich habe als
hartz4 glaube ich nur schaffen es fiel
auf mannschaft und ist ein friedliches
sollte ich eigentlich hochgehen ich bin
ich bin jetzt dein spieler sozusagen ist
ja alles was du machst oder gibt ja bei
mir nicht ich hab ihr schaffen
walter ich wollte einfach abhauen weil
ich dachte okay der typ ist dumm hat
sich angezündet und na ja nicht dann hat
dann hat er mir eben weil er mich um in
die decke reihen hat so misst aber es
war eine starke runde leute ich hab sie
durchgefallen
wir sind zwar nicht mal wieder check
franz aus delligsen der beschreibung und
bis dahin zum nächsten mal
bis zum nächsten mal sich daher
neuerlich tschüss